hey guys if you want to motivate
yourself to crush in life and support
this kind of content at the same time
check out anime upper calm where you can
get your very own hasta dream big work
hard shirt link in the description what
up guys goes in here for anime uproar
and today I'm going to be ranking the
Opie magic night captains from weakest
to strongest a lot of you let me know
that you'd like to see this video on my
all nine magic night captain's and their
powers explained video so here it is if
you want to see more black clover videos
smash that like button to let me know
and let me know in the comments what
video you would like to see next if you
haven't joined the black bowls of
YouTube by subscribing and wringing that
magic YouTube Bell and then Finn rah
will be sure to teleport future black lo
rakaat then straight to you if you want
even more black clover content and want
to share your thoughts with us about the
black clover anime or manga follow us on
Instagram and Twitter warning there will
be manga spoilers in this video because
there's no way I could actually explain
my reasoning without using all the info
available keep in mind this list uses
evidence from the series but we have not
necessarily seen what every magic night
captain is capable of and some have had
more opportunities to show off their
skills than others so at the end of the
day this is more so my opinion rather
than objective indisputable fact if you
would rank the captain's differently
yourself you can let me know how exactly
you drank them in the comments now
without further ado let's jump into the
rankings the weakest magic knight
captain is Gelder plazo he used to be
the captain of the purple orchids before
it was discovered that he betrayed the
kingdom he used his transparency magic
alternatively translated as permeation
magic it can make him invisible and
impervious to magic attacks for a
limited time his magic can also not be
sensed during this period of time
although those who know how to read key
can still figure out where he is when he
used the power to try and escape from
the other magic Knight captain's
Charlotte even said that for a short
amount of time he's invincible however
this isn't really the case because he
can still be hit by physical attacks and
if someone can read key they can take
him out relative
easily as Austin did Gelder's power
allowed him to use dirty tricks to gain
wealth and improve his rank if it wasn't
for his shady behind-the-scenes dealings
he probably would not have been able to
even acquire the title of magic knight
captain so it makes sense that he is on
the bottom of this list I'm not trying
to sell his powers short they're
actually pretty awesome considering that
no one other than Yami and hasta for the
time being can read key Gelder can also
create invisible soldiers to attack
others and has a spell called
invisible traveling companion which he
can use to make another person invisible
and intangible to magic as well so the
power can be very useful and is not bad
by any means but as I said before this
is a list of all P mages the best of the
best so Gelder ended up this low because
the others are even stronger next up we
have rail the captain of the Asura dear
squad in the youngest magic knight
captain in history he is only 19 years
old now this was actually a difficult
decision for me because rail has one of
if not the most Opie magic which is
picture magic alternatively translated
as painting magic it allows him to
create anything he paints and according
to Walter grills imagination and
creativity are infinite which would mean
theoretically his power is as well
unlike most other mages he is not
limited by a magic type since his magic
can generate any element considering his
magic and age I think he has the
potential to eventually become one of
the strongest people on this list but I
finally decided to place him here for a
few reasons mainly it is because he
lacks the experience that the other
captains have this inexperience is
reflected in the fact that his team the
oz or Deer squad ranked at the bottom of
the latest Star Awards festival
furthermore despite being a magic knife
captain he managed to lose the final
round of the crystal destruction battle
tournament now yes you know is extremely
strong and yes we'll only lost because
of how powerful his own magic was but
the fact remains that he lost real
accidentally destroying his own crystal
with his own magic shows his
inexperience when compared to the other
magic knight captain since he lost track
of what was going on in the heat of
battle a more experienced magic knight
captain could
they'll take advantage of that kind of
weakness in a fight another factor that
shaped my decision is the fact that real
has weaker statistics than most magic
knight captains according to the
official data book while he got a 5 out
of 5 in magic amount magic control and
creativity his customized category
he had subpar scores in physical
strength a 2 out of 5 and cleverness a 3
out of 5 physical strength and
cleverness can end up being very
important in combat which is partly why
I placed them where I did on this list
real definitely has a lot of room for
improvement but for the time being I
couldn't place him any higher next up we
have Charlotte Rosalie the captain of
the blue rose squad with her breyer
magic she usually has a handle of a
sword and briars come rushing out of it
and she can manipulate them at will
although she does not actually need the
sword handle to fight with her powers so
what do we know about how strong
Charlotte is we know she fought Raya and
was unable to overpower him before the
fight was interrupted although she was
not defeated either later when her body
gets taken over by the elf Charlotte
Charlotte enhances Charlotte's powers
nevertheless sharla is unable to defeat
a Yami that is trying to capture her
without hurting Charlotte's body Sharla
has to retreat although it seems clear
that Yami could have won if he did not
have to worry about holding back for
Charlotte's sake as a noblewoman
charlotte possesses a vast amount of
magic although as seen with the fight
against Yami slashes can potentially
bisects her magics power and cancel out
her attacks even if her magic is
overwhelmingly greater than her
opponents if we don't count the
customized category that's different for
everyone
Charlotte stats are more impressive than
rails while she also got a perfect fight
of five magic amount in control she
scored a solid 4 out of 5 in physical
strength and cleverness
she's a strong captain but at the same
time there are definitely stronger ones
following Charlotte we have Jack the
Ripper the captain of the green mantis
squad Jack uses Semmering magic which
allows him to create mana blades which
tend to sprout out of his arms he can
also shoot mana blades at his opponent's
sort of like Yami does with his dark
magic Jack can adjust his blades
properties to match his enemies magic so
given enough time there's nothing he
can't cut so far we've seen Jack
participate in the fight against the
three men
of the Midnight Sun he fought against
vetto jack is very comfortable in his
abilities when he shows up he is not at
all daunted by the members of the
Midnight Sun he actually tells Yami that
it's not fair that he was fighting fun
opponents alone and even questions
whether they are worth spicing up he has
a rivalry going on with the ami which in
itself demonstrates how strong he is and
his goal is to beat the black bull
captain when he is at 100%
according to finra people also refer to
jack as a destruction fiend who wants to
slice up the whole world he not only
survived the fight against Yami
he even shaved the whole mountain the
way in the process jack appears to have
no trouble fighting against vetto and
even has time to worry about nose el who
gets matched up with fauna who has no
cells elemental weakness and the fire
speared salamander to boots
yes nose el if he wants to switch
because the fact that fire is super
effective against his mercury magic
later on Jack fights alongside Yami
against fin Rahl's immensely talented
and elf possessed brother at this point
we discovered that Jack can even cut
through spatial magic like Yami's dai
mentioned / in regards to his statistics
he scored a 4 out of 5 and physical
strength a 4 out of 5 a magic amount of
5 out of 5 a magic control of 4 out of 5
in magic sensing and a 4 out of 5 in
cleverness his statistics are similar to
Charlotte's except he got an extra point
on magic sensing well she got an extra
point on magic amount however I please
Jack above because of his destructive
reputation his ability to keep up with
Yami and the fact that Jack's lashes
weren't very similar to Yami's and so
just as it was with the ami slashes
Jack's own slashes would be effective at
dealing with Charlotte's prior magic
next I have no Zell Silva the captain of
the Silver Eagle squad who possesses
mercury magic he can manipulate his
mercury in many ways allowing him to use
it as a defense as a short mid or long
range attack and as a ride now I
initially struggled with whether I
should put him above Jack because he
managed to be brought down by the elf
given but ultimately I decided to put
him ahead in his defense Kevin was said
to be the strongest elf in the area
according to know Zell and while Jack
had another holy night captain Yami by
his side
no Zell only had Noel who only later
unlocked
amazing power when it was needed and
used it to defeat the strong elf who
injured know Zell aside from that know
Zell was able to fight fauna just as
Charlotte was able to fight Raya and
Jack was able to fight meadow without
being overpowered this is even more
impressive for know Zell because he was
fighting against his elemental weakness
fire and not only that but fauna
possessed a fire speared salamander
which drastically increased her already
strong fire powers nose elves rival is
Fugo Leon someone who also strives to be
the strongest and become the wizard King
the fact that no Zell can compete with
someone else who has his elemental
weakness and is as strong as Fugo Leon
also goes to show his strength while he
scored the same as Jack in the other
categories know Zell beat him in magic
amount because know Zell is a nobleman
he has a large reserve of magic to use
combine that with the speed of his
mercury magic and is difficult to escape
attacks like silver rain and I have to
put nose L above Jack Jack can
eventually cut through anything but it
takes time while no Zell has many quick
ways to take out an opponent after know
Zell we have William von gents the
captain of the Golden Dawn squad now we
are really getting into some
ridiculously powerful characters keep in
mind that I am thinking of William
independently and not including Patri
since there are different characters
even if they share the same body
William's magic is world tree magic we
haven't seen him use it a lot but what
he has used has been extremely
impressive to spell great mistltein tree
which creates roots in the ground that
absorbs surrounding mana and then a
giant tree appears that can capture many
enemies at once some drawbacks of the
spell are that it takes time and the
size of it depends on the mana in the
area so William cannot always create as
big of a tree he can also throw a small
seed at an opponent that will quickly
grow into a large tree trapping the
opponent inside the Golden Dawn Squad
has been called the strongest squad and
William bond gents is their leader which
goes to show how powerful he is at the
beginning of the series he is also said
to be the top candidate to be the next
wizard king so to truly understand the
significance of that statement let's
look at what it means to be the wizard
King julius tells awesome you know that
one becomes the wizard king through
eret Julius explains that what people
want from a wizard King is achievements
that mark you as the strongest so he
tells Austin you know and I quote to
devote yourselves to building a
reputation that's everything and quote
so the fact that William is considered
to be the top candidate suggests that so
far he has marked himself to be the
strongest through his achievements and
attained a great reputation however the
fact that Julius places such an emphasis
on building your reputation suggests
that it is not necessarily the strongest
mage that will become wizard King if
that mage doesn't care about reputation
so the fact that William is the top
candidate definitely means he's strong
but even more so it means he's been able
to build a good reputation for being
strong up to this point however I do
believe that there are stronger mages
than him like the next one I will
mention who has no interest in becoming
the next wizard King that character is
none other than the uncrowned undefeated
lioness meteo Leona
medal they own a possesses fire magic
and her fights are some of my favorite
moments in the whole series because of
how epic and strong she truly is medow
Leona doesn't like being in the capital
so she spends 300 days a year away
basking in nature's mana which
strengthens her mana skin making her to
use Zoras words a monster when it comes
to battle thus she's actually more than
strong enough to be a magic night
captain but she wasn't one before
because she didn't want to be and she
wouldn't want to be the wizard King
either so even if she is stronger than
William she would not be considered the
top candidate even if we ignore the fact
though that meta Oh Leona would in all
likelihood have a significant elemental
advantage against Williams tree magic
her accomplishments in the series so far
would definitely suggest that she is
stronger than him for instance Patri
possesses a magic light magic which I
would not view as being inferior to tree
magic furthermore Patri has the same
stats that William has except he beats
William in physical strength he gets a
four out of five rather than three out
of five thus I would assume that Patri
is about equal to William in strength if
not stronger Patri has said that Riya
along with fauna and vetto are more
powerful than him in combat and yet
metal alone a completely overpowered
Briah with his third eye open witch
would suggest that he's even stronger at
this point than when he fought Charlotte
not only that but in what is probably
the most epic fight of the series meadow
Leona was able to fight against five
elves one of them being Raya and another
being an elf possessed reule
and actually stand her ground until
hasta and Zora came back to rescue her
she's truly an epically strong character
and deserves to be very high up on this
list next we have Dorothy Unsworth the
captain of the coral peacock squad it
was only recently that we figured out
her magic and oh man is it ever Opie I
knew Tabata was saving it for a reason
and that was definitely the case dorothy
possesses dream magic she creates and
pulls surrounding people into a
dreamlike world also referred to as a
magical dimension where Dorothy has
control and can think anything into
existence within that world on top of
that Dorothy's magic can make those in
her world grow sleepier and sleepier and
those that fall asleep will never wake
up again so not only is the power ope to
begin with it can also make the opponent
sleepier and sleepier as time goes on as
sally says the user of dream magic is
invincible in the dreamlike world so
they have to escape that world before
they can hope to defeat her
Sally also discovers one drawback of the
spell which is that people can make the
user involuntarily think of things and
as a result involuntarily bring those
things into the dream world eventually
the only way that the team can beat the
elf that's possessing Dorothy is by
having her imagined a real Dorothy then
the dream world collapses because it
cannot support both the elfs and
Dorothy's dreams at the same time so in
the end it takes Dorothy to beat her own
opie magic if Dorothy used her magic
since she has more experience with the
magic and probably better control over
her thoughts through training chances
are she would be much more difficult to
defeat that even the elf was there are
only two people that I think are
stronger than Dorothy and I'll explain
why one of them is fugu Leon Vermillion
the captain of the crimson lion squad
he possesses fire magic like his sister
meadow Leone before he entered his coma
Mariola Luna was likely stronger than
him but we recently got some big news
fugu Leon woke up from his coma and
somehow managed to inherit a grown
salamander the fire spirit that was
previously possessed by fauna salamander
at this stage of its growth will
dramatically increase Peugeot Leon's
power which was already astonishing I
believe that the fire spirit is enough
to put Fugo Lian above his sister on
this list furthermore Fugo Lian was
ranked as the smartest captain he scored
a perfect 5 out of 5 in cleverness while
his sister only scored 4 out of 5 his
intelligence would dramatically
increases likelihood of being able to
escape from Dorothy's dreamworld spell
although he was defeated by Patri in the
past yami told Patri that he never could
have defeated Peugeot Lian if he didn't
play dirty
what pottery likely did was pretend to
be William Vaughn chance to get Fugo
Lian to lower his guard before he
attacked him
so Yami believed that Fugo Lian wouldn't
have lost to poetry in a fair fight even
though Yami himself could not succeed in
defeating poetry in a one-on-one fight
at this point in fact he needed help
from gauche and auste and Patri still
managed to escape things Surya vetto and
fauna
Yami's words go to show how strong from
go Lian already was even before he
inherited the opie fire spirit
salamander now a salamander and his
intellect he'll be near invincible and
for those reasons I have to put Fugo
Lian high up on this list and lastly the
strongest captain is Yami suka hito the
captain of the black bolts Yami
possesses dark magic and overcomes the
slowness of the dark magic by combining
it with his katana he channels his dark
magic into his slashes so similar to
Jack the Ripper he can send slashes
flying at his opponent now why did I
place Yami so high well there's quite a
few reasons first off in terms of
physical strength he comes in first
place not only among the captains but
among all of the characters we've seen
so far however he also scored a perfect
5 out of 5 and magic amount so Yami is
the best of both worlds he has also
significantly improved as the series
began he actually learned his strongest
move since then called dark cloak
dimension slash the attack allows him to
cut through dimensions like Jack he can
use this attack to cut through spatial
magic but unlike with Jack Yami doesn't
need the extra time that it takes Jack
to adjust to the opponent's magic he
learned this attack after he had that
dust-up with Jack and chances are Yami
probably always had the upper hand since
Jack mentions at one point that he has
passed grudge
against the ami which could come from
the fact that he couldn't ever beat Yami
in a fight after Yami learned his newest
strongest move Jack would stand even
less of a chance
Yami's new move would probably allow him
to quickly escape from the magical
dimension that Dorothy can create even
before he learned dark clothes I
mentioned / he was able to fight against
Patri and even survive against the
attacks of fauna vetto and raya long
enough for the other three captains to
arrive he wasn't even worried he was
ready to surpass his limits and even
complained that something was about to
awaken in him in another second or so
now this is comedic but it's not far
from the truth
his customized category in the data book
was limit surpassing and he scored a
perfect 5 out of 5 in that that ability
is what allowed him to unlock dark
cloaked I mentioned / when he did and it
is something that must be considered
when we are talking about how strong he
is I placed him on top of this list
because he's the strongest captain
physically he has an insane amount of
magic he has the Opie moved our cloak
that mentioned / and he is known for his
ability to surpass his limits when the
situation calls for it and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watching like I said this is my opinion
but I try to inform that opinion with as
much evidence as possible if you think
differently that's totally cool you can
let me know how you would rank the
captains in the comments obviously
Kaiser grande Borka the new captain of
the purple orcas had to be left out
because we know nothing about his magic
and we've never seen him fight yet so
speculating as to how he match up with
the others would have been pretty
pointless I definitely look forward to
learning about his powers though if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
black clover content on this channel
definitely smash that like one too let
me know if you haven't yet be sure to
subscribe and ring that magic youtube
else so finra can keep teleporting these
videos to you let me know what videos
you want to see next but only if you are
passionately burning up to see them
thanks again I love our own black bull
squad that we've been able to create and
grow here on YouTube and I feel so lucky
that I get to do this every day until
next time see ya space cowboy
[Music]
you